[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to if you one of the Game of
Thrones fans that was disappointed with
the ending of season 8 then fear not
because a fan named coloured comics has
taken to Twitter with the re-edited
scene that makes the ending of the show
infinitely more amazing the 30-second
clip shows us what we could have got but
never mind I'll just play it now so you
can see for yourself
[Music]
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
[Music]
how good was that I mean just it's just
so much better and right let's just run
it again cuz I need to re-watch it
[Music]
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
[Music]
okay so for me this is actually the
ending that I'm gonna go with from now
in my head
bran still could have been the master
manipulator of the entire thing and he
of course could have used his foresight
and control over animals and such to
puppeteer everyone into letting him be
king it's the only explanation that fits
for me right now as to why the character
eventually reached that position as he
didn't really ever show that side of
himself that would make me think that
he's a good leader he is however a
master manipulator like a lot of the
characters in the show and this ending
is pretty much what I'm gonna have in my
head when I go back and we watch it it's
the only way I can actually be happy
with it and it also ties in the fan
theories that bran was indeed the night
king which is probably my favorite one
from the show obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this video and if you
prefer it over the ending that we got
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you head over to Khaled
comics to congratulate him on the video
I'll leave a link to his Twitter below
so definitely go over and check out his
page you've also just dropped a video on
everything we know so far about the
spin-offs of Game of Thrones so make
sure you click the link to that at the
end for more videos like this this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]